the faults Pune in Berlin has a storied
history as a center for left-wing
theater an appropriate setting for a new
European group of left-wing politicians
to take a bow and the star of the
evening was former greek Finance
Minister Yanis varoufakis he's fighting
for what he calls a new more democratic
Europe the European Union's
disintegration is happening new
divisions new walls are springing up
along the borders of our nation's inside
our societies in people's minds and
hearts Fair Folk has challenged
Europeans to come together but said of
new Europe should allow countries more
independence and he says more
transparency is urgently needed a
transparent Europe where all
decision-making that takes place under
the citizen scrutiny today we have
transparent citizens and opaque
governments we must reverse this he also
says important European Union debate
should be broadcast live to the public
and he insists the EU should get out of
the banking business as well as public
budgets so tonight let's celebrate but
room tomorrow morning let's shake Europe
gently compassionately but firmly his
new movement is called m25 it doesn't
aim to achieve political objectives as
such instead the group aims to be a
platform for radical thinking about
democracy whether or not that may one
day lead to setting up a political party
faroe focus didn't say